in this talk I would like to talk to you
first to you first about firebase and
what firebase is what it can do for you
what it can do for your apps I'll show
you a few examples I'll talk you through
the whole thing but then I will also
introduce you to some of my friends here
from new Pantanal new sports they have
built an actual app on all the stuff
that I will be talking to you about and
they're excited to tell you about their
app but first let me tell you a little
bit about what a firebase is firebase is
basically your front door to Google's
cloud if you build apps and apps in the
broadest sense of the word be it mobile
apps or a web app if you are building
something with a small team if you're
building something with mobile users or
web users you can use firebase as your
front door to Google's cloud what would
that bring you well firebase has a suite
of products that help you with app
development and it works on all
platforms it works on iOS and Android
clearly these are the dominant mobile
platforms as well as the web as well as
for game developers C++ unity the whole
shebang so on all of those platforms we
can give you a number of tools that will
help you develop your app I'll talk
through a number of the highlights but
the key point of this slide is quite how
many there are and there turn out to be
many issues that you need to solve when
you build an app and we hope to attack
at least all of the hard ones for you so
that you can spend more time doing the
fun code and we do the nasty part for
you so let's dive into a few of the
features that help you develop your app
we have a few features as well that help
you grow your usage etc once you have a
successful app but let's first dive into
how you develop an app the first feature
and the one that many many people start
with
when they start to use firebase is our
real-time database and this is it's a no
sequel database it's a database that can
store imagine it as an object in the
cloud and your applications can connect
to parts of that object listen to
changes it does a whole bunch of stuff
for you for example the synchronization
between devices let's say that you have
a bunch of devices that are all
interested in the same set of your data
for example I right now I'm carrying two
phones as well as a laptop and the
tablet in my bag over there I might have
them with me all the time if I press a
button on my phone I would like to see
the change on my laptop as well
the real-time database does all of that
for you
this is the real time or the real time
part of it is that when I press that
button on my phone it immediately
changes on all of my other devices as
well as well it takes care of that
synchronization for me the other part
that is cool is that it does
reconciliation of things like poor
connectivity so let's say that my
tablets that is making a change is
currently offline because the Wi-Fi here
is oversubscribed with thousands of
people and it doesn't currently have a
connection
it'll buffer those updates and when my
tablet next comes online again it'll
sync all of those changes to all my
other devices and I didn't have to write
a line of code to make that happen so
compare this to a model where you would
write your own API you would have to
deal with the fact that your tablet was
offline you would have to deal with the
fact that maybe other changes have
happened in the meantime
etc etc all of them all that done for
you authentication is the next feature
that I think many people look at
authentication does user sign-in either
with username and password or with a
phone with an with a phone number with
SMS verification or with an OAuth
provider something like Google or
Facebook or your own existing off system
if you already have it as well as
anonymous and a whole bunch more
so this is a problem that every app
developer has approximately you need to
sign in your users you need to know who
they are
firebase off does it for you with an
out-of-the-box UI in about two lines of
code so the next time you're reading a
login page
don't hosting will let you host a
website and it'll give you a free SSL
certificate it'll connect to your
existing domain we have storage which
lets you put large files in the cloud
and there's a whole bunch more of these
features that help you do things that
many app developers need and many app
developers have had to reinvent in the
past no more now let's say that you have
an existing app and you like it and your
users like it and they use it but you'd
like there to be more users or you'd
like your users to be more engaged
hopefully this is a problem you will get
to once you have an app that works and
so we have a number of features that
help you grow your app firebase Cloud
messaging helps you do things like send
messages to your users things like push
notifications etc are something that
many of us have had to build in the past
firebase Cloud messaging helps you do
that remote configuration helps you do
things like hmm I have built a game and
level 3 is a little bit too hard and I'm
losing too many gamers at that level let
me tweak down the difficulty level of
that level a little bit done and what
remote configuration does is it
synchronizes that basically parameter
change to all of your other to all of
your users to the million users that
have installed your app without them
having to update their app great
analytics if any of you have ever used
Google Analytics on the web you have
thought to yourself wow what would I do
without it because it tells you so much
about what your users are doing on the
website it tells you so much about where
they came from now you can do all of
that in your app as well and I do
promise you if you have an app that uses
this your next app
also use it because you will never want
to do without it again the nice thing
about analytics is that it is a free
product so by the way all of the
products I talked about are free to use
for like hobby sort of things you can
experiment with it today if you want no
credit card needed even analytics is
free forever so you can use it for you
know I don't know if you're new Pantanal
for example so we have many many cool
features that help you build apps this
is just like a few of them but how do
you put them all together how do you
meld them all into one app and respond
to what happens in all of these
different systems as things happen the
answer to that oh sorry
the I I can give a few examples where
this is a problem for example if I were
using a traditional back-end not
firebase all of these things would be
hard for example let's say that I want
to send a notification to my users when
they have received a new chat message I
need to be running a back-end that
back-end has to be able to receive
messages from users all across the globe
it has to be able to persist those
messages somewhere and then have some
sort of integration with for example
firebase Cloud messaging to send out the
message to the user who received a
message or another example resizing
images once a user uploads a photo to
firebase cloud storage let's take that
example and dive into it a little bit
more so I have an app and it wants to
upload a picture to storage and resize
it in the past what you would do is you
would talk to your custom back-end and
it would say aha let me place the
original in once in one place on on
storage and then let me resize the image
and put it in a different place on
storage tada I'm done
great this seems like it would work and
it seems effortless right until you
realize that yes this gives you the
thumbnailing the resizing it does not
give you resumable
loads of your original picture it does
not give you resumable downloads of
either the result or the original
picture it does not give you end user
authentication whether they were
permitted to write that picture in the
first place it does not give you a
pay-as-you-go sort of you know cloudy
model that we've come to come to love
because you know you have to run that
physical virtual machine or even a piece
of actual hardware so it's not a
pay-as-you-go model and it certainly
isn't global scale unless you do a lot
of work to do this all across the globe
and then again you will pay even more so
using firebase instead of that
traditional back-end
all of these things become a whole lot
easier thanks to cloud functions this is
the newest item in our lineup the newest
product in our develop tier of products
and it makes all of these things easier
so let's take another look at the
example of the photo being uploaded the
wavefunctions works is something happens
and you'd like to do something in
response great so for example a photo is
uploaded to cloud storage and I would
like to create the thumbnail using cloud
functions that is really easy because
this photo uploaded to cloud storage is
an event you receive that event as a
cloud function you trigger off that you
do something for example creating the
thumbnail to give a little bit more of a
complicated example let's dive into the
realm of machine learning which I know a
lot of lots of you have heard about
today before things like I upload a
sound file I might say got the cloud
speech API understands that this is
Dutch that I just spoke transcribes it
and puts that into a database so we used
a cloud function to realize that a sound
file had been uploaded to the cloud to
push that to the cloud machine learning
the cloud speech API which does machine
learning to recognize that speech and we
brought it back to firebase but now now
I've written this back to firebase
firebase has an event which is something
was written to the database and we can
trigger off of that again and we can say
okay let me translate the word cut into
English for example and get the result
cat and write that back into the
database so we built a pipeline a data
pipeline of sorts with machine learning
etc built in with well this turns out to
be about 10-ish lines of code the
example that I gave here actually exists
you can go to say that IO slash source
and you can see on github the code that
we've written for that and you can clone
it play with it and it works so you're
wondering what sort of events can I
trigger
cloud functions off of well first and
foremost we have HTTP endpoints this is
a pretty standard I'd say model that
we're used to somebody comes and hits
your website basically you want to
respond to that this generates dynamic
content it's great for generating
dynamic websites but since this is in
the firebase world we also work with the
firebase real time database we work with
cloud pub/sub with authentication this
is the the user sign in system that I
just talked about so for example a new
user signs up you would like to hear
about it great cloud storage for
firebase as well as Google Analytics for
firebase this is the the tool that tells
you what your users are doing in the app
so for example you might get something
like a oh my oh dear there was a crash
and this user is one of the most
valuable users that I have let me send
them a coupon code just to say sorry
great that engages your user it keeps
the high value user in your app even
though they've just had a bad experience
firebase hosting lets you host your web
pages now those web pages can be
dynamically generated using functions
and we have more of these coming up soon
so here's an example of some actual code
for a cloud function I should pause for
a moment and say you've probably heard
about cloud functions before me just
standing here from other people standing
here cloud functions exists in the wider
cloud world as well in the firebase
world the app development world we've
added a few tricks to make things easier
for you and so for example in this case
we're using nodejs and this nodejs
imports an sdk that we've written for
you to make writing functions as easy as
we could make it so our top line says I
will import this SDK that we've written
and then we export a function and we're
gonna call it hello world gee how
creative and we say functions this is an
HTTP function and I would like you to
respond to a request you get the request
in the response object and when the
actual request happens this is much like
an OGS Express app if you've ever used
any of these before and you can send the
result that you would like now the cool
thing about this is to get this running
in the cloud all you do is type on your
command line firebase deploy if I go
back one step you see that in this line
we had all of the information we needed
to create a function that actually runs
in the cloud and what we do when you run
firebase deploy here we read your code
for you we see what functions you would
like to run in the cloud we run them for
you it is that easy
there's no flags it is for me at least
the simplest solution that I know of
running code in a globally scalable way
here's a slightly more complicated
example the thing I wanted to call out
here is that the system works the same
when you have not a like
not a an HTTP endpoint but a database
event that you want to listen to so for
example you say functions database
when there is a write to the following
reference on that right give me an event
and trigger a bunch of code and this
particular code is an example where we
take the timestamp of the right and we
write it to the database so that we can
always persist a timestamp with every
write that happens so this is the old
world that we were in before we were
using firebase where our mobile apps had
to talk to an API that had to talk to a
back end and the back end maybe had some
custom code running in it etc in the new
world you take your custom code you
upload it to the cloud to firebase and
it glues the whole application together
so by using the various firebase
features we address all the various pain
points you get during app development
and we just get from zero to app much
much faster than we did before and by
using functions all of those different
features now feel like one platform so
that's my brief interpret the
introduction to what firebase is what
you might use it for and how you use
functions which we're all very excited
about but you've probably heard a lot of
Googlers talk about yeah I'm so excited
about the thing that I work on which is
true but for you I think it's much more
interesting to hear about an actual use
case something from the real world
people who've actually used firebase to
to great effect so I would like to
invite up my friends from new sport and
they're gonna tell you about a real app
using firebase
yes thanks for a cool presentation RG
and so we are from new sport as you
might know that part of militant L and
we would like to show you today have
used firebase to create the fastest
sport up of the Netherlands my name is
Yvonne and my colleague is Johnny is one
of our awesome back-end developers at
little Terrell so brief introduction
about new sport new sport is sport at
its best and what we aim to do is to
provide real-time instantaneous news to
our users about their favorite sport
events even if they are more of them at
the same time so some facts and figures
new support has around 300,000 downloads
1.3 million weekly pageviews and we are
also quite happy that our users engage
so during matches we have for example
pause and we have usually around 10,000
poll votes on this vote which is very
nice and we also have 1500 blocks weekly
in the app which might sound weird at
the moment but as soon as you will see
had a new sport that looks then you will
see what I mean by that so a bit spoiled
this already but the goal of the new
sport that is to be the fastest sport
that of the Netherlands in short and
there's an interesting thing I would
like to mention about the development of
the new sport app so we started to
create a new new sport app last year
before the Champions League so we want
it to be done for the Champions League
and I don't know how is it usually at
your organization but at ours it can
happen sometimes that we have quite
challenging deadlines and it was also
the case with new sport so we had to
month to develop two apps from scratch
and also create the real-time backend
and the clients and everything we need
for it so we had a few options to do
that one of the options was to go to the
market and then yeah buy a complete
third-party package software package
with the real-time backend with clients
everything but that cost quite some
money and we like to spare money where
it's possible so that was not an option
the other option was to create the
real-time back-end and the clients
ourself but back then we didn't have too
much experience with that and due to the
it would have been quite challenging
with experimenting and everything so we
also didn't want to do that so our best
option was to choose firebase so we did
that and there are also some other
reasons why we chose firebase so I want
you to mention three here it's fast it
scales with you and it's cost efficient
so it's not only fast in the sense that
you will soon see in the demo when we
push something to the abbot it yeah
shows instantaneously in real time but
it's also fast in the sense that it's
really easy to implement for iOS and for
Android as well and you can implement it
really easily and fast it also scales
with you which is really important for
us because as you might imagine the
nature of the new sport there is a bit
cyclical so for example in a business
Sunday when max first opera is rocking
it in Formula One we have an IX and
Feyenoord game and maybe even cycling
event going on then we have much more
users then on a boring Tuesday morning
at 9:00 a.m. when there's nothing
happening so it's very important for us
that yeah our systems can scale with us
and firebase just just does that and
that leads to my next point it's also
quite cost-efficient because as Roberto
mentioned it's a pay-as-you-go model so
obviously on Sundays when we have more
users and higher loads and you use more
data we pay more but on Tuesdays when
it's boring then we pay less and that
also keeps our managers happy quite cost
so how are we actually using firebase I
would like to mention three features
here which are interesting the real-time
database so if you look at the app then
you see that we have some blocks and
this is a this is actually a time line
and as the new sport events come in then
they always end up on the top right so
it's a bit like a Twitter timeline and
we use different blocks to show these
news bits to our users so we have
pictures videos Instagram Twitter blogs
all type of things
and this is all done with the help of
firebase we also have Paul blogs and
also we have the scoreboard which you
can see in the top there which obviously
have to update non-stop because the
match is going on so you need to show
the minutes of the of
game and the goals and that's done in
real time and the user doesn't need to
do anything so he doesn't need to swipe
down or press something but it's just
being pushed to his device and it's all
and the user obvious is the newest
information so that's pretty cool
we also use cloud messaging so obviously
views push notifications and we used it
to personalize the experience of the
users in the app so users can sign up
for different sports like football
formula bomb cycling and they get the
most important news delivered in the
form of push messages and another
interesting thing is remote config we
use this to optimize a bit the user
experience in the app so when you open
the app we can set remotely on the fly
without needing to submit a new app to
the App Store or whatever we can set how
many blocks appear for you on the screen
so in this way we can optimize the
loading speed of the app so these are
things that we are doing now that we
also have some additional plans the
first man planned to implement firebase
for new data now and this we already
achieved actually so as you imagine you
can imagine new dot NL app is a totally
different scale than a new sport app so
new data Nell is the biggest new site of
the Netherlands we have millions and
millions of users every month so when we
use firebase for breaking news events so
when something really big happens and
you come to our website or apps so we
use it on iOS Android and web when you
come to the website then if you click on
the article about the breaking news
event then you will see the same block
structure as you can see in the news
portal so we use firebase there as well
and it works really well it's also
scales really good enduring these yeah
breaking news events when we have like
hundreds of thousands of people yeah
coming to our FSM website and firebase
analytics you can do really cool things
with firebase analytics and also in
combination with all the firebase
products so for example with cloud
messaging in the new sport for example
we could create user groups to user
segments on the fly so if we see that
people are clicking on at the I oxen
feyenoord blocks then we can create a
segment and send a push notification
only to those people who click on these
blocks with something personal with the
promotion or whatsoever so you can do
really cool
things with that and cloud functions
back then when we started to develop the
new sport app cloud functions was not
available yet so we didn't use it at the
start but now since it's available we
see some really cool opportunities how
we can implement it and that's something
what Johnny will tell you more about
with the demo yes thank you is fun hi
everybody I will give you a small demo
of the new support app if you can just
unlock the phone so yes it works
so here you can see our content
management system in the first column
this is where we add the blocks we have
several types of blocks
I will demo the text block but as you
can see if I click here there's a
drop-down list with some types we
integrated Facebook Instagram we can add
polls etc the middle column is the
firebase console where you can see our
database which is a pretty simple
structure but before you get to there
when you used to using relational
database that's kind of tricky but we
managed it and it's working and the last
column is the actual app and you can see
a squirt block and an image block and at
the bottom there is a text block and you
can see them also here inside a content
management system and I will add a new
text block something like I am Johnny
you sport koala is red cash me outside
about that
so I store it and you see it added to
the firebase database and instantly
being added inside the app and what's
cool is we don't have the load of the
user so if we have one user or if we
have a million users everyone connects
to the firebase database so if a very
simple machine running are up in surfer
and we don't have to you have to scale
up when more users are added so I can of
course also edit the block just type in
mistake you can see here and some here
so when I store it you'll see an update
coming here and also the app is also
immediately updated maybe you also
noticed the scoreboard block back to
here it's still sitting on top but I
added a new block and it appeared below
it and we added some functionality we
call painting blocks and you can see
here the scoreboard has a tiny pin edit
and when you add blocks or contents to
firebase you can also add hidden
priority field which is just a number
and it's ordered from 0 to yeah running
so 0 to 9 and we we created something
the the not pin blocks are just a
timestamp of when they are created but
are negative so we have new ones on top
and pin blocks are hard numbers which is
a very low negative number so we can pin
them always on top which is about 100
years and then I won't be here so nobody
will blame me so and that's about it I
think I can also delete it and you can
see deleting from firebase and deleting
from the app and it's it's always fast
so it doesn't matter if 1 million users
are connected to it or one user it just
works instantly so back to the
presentation
and this these are some learnings we had
during development and when we were done
we never done but some somewhat done and
one was the bandwidth usage you were
charged for the bandwidth you are using
we have a pay-as-you-go and you say it's
model model and it turned out that we
were using about one terabyte of data
per month and that was something in our
data structure in the beginning and we
were looking to too much updates so if
you don't subscribe to the right
endpoint inside your database then you
get a lot of updates where users are not
watching so you need to think before you
leap into this this structured it's also
one point in no sequel database which I
already mentioned we're used to using
relational databases and now we had to
flatten our structure and keep all
simple and so that's something yeah it's
not very hard but you need to think
about it beforehand and the final thing
is the sharding and as each one set
firebase kills with you but it skills to
a certain level and we didn't know
before but there is a level and there's
a maximum of 100,000 concurrent users
per firebase project slash database and
since we're also using this for new data
Nell when a news event happens it's
pushed to all our clients and we have
about more than a million clients so if
they all open the app at the same time
they will go to the to the same timeline
and then we will have more than 100,000
users so we talked to Google on how to
fix that and they said well most users
are using sharding for this and what it
is we just have our main database and we
just clone it 20 times so he creates 25
based databases which all contain the
same data and we're updating it from
from our back-end so every time we
update a block we send it to all the 20
shots and the clients just randomly
connect one of those 20 shots and now we
have 20 times 100,000 concurrent
connection possibilities so I think we
can manage with that but we'll see yeah
I think that's it I will give to work
back to r.j.
[Music]
thank you guys so much it's it's always
just exciting to see people using our
our stuff but like new Pantanal using
our stuff is especially exciting to me
personally coming from the Netherlands
thank you guys so much thanks thank you
guys so much and if you would like to
talk to us later we'll be hanging around
for a bit and we'd love to chat thank
you and enjoy the rest of the evening
[Applause]
[Music]